i didn't know
[Music]
i didn't know dmx died i didn't know
it breaks my heart
breaks my heart
stacy dash in tears after learning dmx
died last year you know addiction is an
illness
and explaining why over a year later his
death hits close to home the rapper died
in april 2021 he was 50 years old just
wanted to hear banging songs the
clueless star made a tick-tock video
sobbing after learning the rapper's fade
okay oh
i'm ashamed i
i didn't know
[Music]
i didn't know dmx died
[Music]
from a cocaine overdose
dmx was hospitalized after suffering a
heart attack triggered by drugs a week
later he was pronounced dead
his death hit a nerve with stacy who's
faced demons of her own
excuse me if i do not care i am today
six years
clean i'm so busy
breaks his heart
he lost
to it he lost
he lost that demon
of addiction
[Music]
do you have a drug problem now
i will always have a drug problem
years before his death dmx opened up
about his struggle with drug addiction
just because you stopped getting high
doesn't mean that you don't have the
problem because it's a constant fight
every day
every trigger that was a true you know
it was a trigger when you got it's still
the sugar
whether you act on it or not it's a
lonely feeling it's a lonely feeling
stacy too has been vocal about her
struggles specifically the toll it took
on her health and career
how bad did this addiction get
i was taking 18 to 20 pills a day 18 to
20 vicodin a day that's expensive yeah
i lost everything
stacy continued the conversation on
facebook writing i encourage anyone who
has a story they are scared of telling
to share it with the world i am blessed
to be surrounded by people who have
loved and supported me through my most
challenging time i'm going to let people
know
what i've been through
the value of a support system is
something stacy's opened up about to e.t
i had people who were understanding who
cared about me who saw my talent
and could see that it was a bad
situation that i didn't quite know how
to get out of
in this interview from 2016 she gets
candid about her past revealing
addiction runs in her family there are
so many kids who
when they see their parents in that
struggle you know it's like that fork in
the road
it either scares you straight or it
leads you down the same path
and it led you down the same path for a
little while yeah yeah
until i had my son
when your father passed that
hit you here yeah yeah and that was
because
because i knew he was sick
and
you know addiction is an illness it's
not you know something
that people can control and i know he
loved me so
i know that he couldn't he couldn't beat
it he couldn't beat that demon
[Music]